well you mentioned the dialectical
relationship and the coexistence of the
good and bad and extremism element and
human flourishing in religion and
professor wolf did the same but there's
also an ongoing conflict historically
between notions of so-called extreme
secularism and religiosity so when
you're thinking about applying the good
sides of religion towards actions - for
the betterment of human life for the
whole planet do you think these actions
explicitly backed up by religion will
intimidate the fragile balances in
certain geographies where I come from as
I'm sure you know this is a huge problem
where people are either branded as
extreme secularists or they're branded
as religious conservatives but I mean
there are people as we see one before
ourselves today you who have
internalized both and can act on either
notion depending on what the situation
requires so how can we overcome this and
not intimidate huge numbers of people
again that's a really good point I mean
I think that the the first thing that we
should do is that we don't disrespect
people of no faith you know we didn't I
don't mind I mean I have a curious
background my dad was that is a militant
atheist I mean he talked to my dad about
religion he didn't even talk to me you
know and I think there is an aggressive
secularism but there is a perfectly
rational humanist perspective and I
think it's important that we engage with
that and also understand that but I
think it's important too that you know
we explore the secular religious Fizz
the state because that is a specific
question which obviously is highly
topical and controversial in Turkey but
also what are the limits of humanism and
what is the extra dimension that faith
can bring which i think is also a
something that is worth examining of
what we think maybe so one of the things
that we will actually do in the course
of the courses actually explore the
issues to do with faith in democracy
faith and the state and I think it's you
know for myself right at the outset I
should say to you that though I am a
person of faith I don't you know I don't
find it difficult to have a dialogue
with people who aren't you know I
respect their their right to believe
differently you know just as long as
they respect mine to believe what I
believe